150 residents
150 different stories of struggling to
get by mostly over 50 many on their own
all looking for hope
it comes in many forms like this man
Keenan from feedback which hands out
food teaches low-cost cooking classes
and runs an allotment to help feed the
neighbors I think the first thing that
we hear when we talk to people are the
concerns about food prices rising and
about energy prices rising as well so
how do people here actually coping we've
had conversations with people where
they've said they're actually going to
each other's homes whenever somebody's
actually got money on the meter to to
heat their home they're having to
alternate homes his colleague Lucy says
they need help more than ever but not
the sort offered by Liz truss's
government last week how did you feel
when you watched the government's energy
and growth statement on Friday
um a mixture of anger and a certain
amount of Despair it's so deeply unfair
and there's a there's a sort of
narrative about oh you need to work
harder people cannot work any harder
than they're already doing it's only
three days since that mini budget in
here they're hunkered down today
insisting their plan would work in the
face of a market sell-off I'm not going
to be able to comment on particular
Market movements and there are various
factors that always go into those but
the government is absolutely focused on
delivering the growth package as we set
out with various ways that will be
helping both businesses and households
to move ahead to growth and as I say to
Greater opportunity that didn't seem to
reassure many here in Liverpool nor calm
nervatory MPS anxious about what happens
when a party loses its reputation for
financial credibility they remember the
1997 general election Landslide defeat
and they'll watch as labor gathers here
in Liverpool to try and claim the mantle
of the party of economic competence the
headline promise more nurses and
midwives paid for by restoring the top
rate of tax but focused two on the
turmoil caused by the new government the
chancellor and prime minister meanwhile
resembled two desperate gamblers in a
casino chasing a losing run
but here's the thing
they're not gambling with their money
they're gambling with yours
they've lost credibility they're losing
confidence they're out of control
here they already want more from Liz
truss's government but they also know
what it's like when there's no money
left Sam Coates Sky News Liverpool